good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy tuesday hope
everyone's having a
fabulous sickening day i mean i wouldn't
call it fabulous and sickening just yet
i really wouldn't
i thought i was going to start today on
like such a great foot yesterday was
kind of a wash for me
i took the day off after the toast
because my allergies were bad and i'm
just like i'm going to stay indoors
and try and get better and so i was like
today is the day but i already left my
coffee at home
i already forgot to put on deodorant oh
my god that's
so wait did you forget to put on okay no
but i've been i came on the show today
with a story to tell about deodorant
because like oh my that is so
crazy that is so crazy and i know why
because i'm wearing a collared shirt
under my
sweatshirt so i thought i would put it
on like after i put on my clothes even
though like i never want to do that
that's crazy you have to do it before
before
your clothes enter it's not going to
happen every time i do my makeup i then
go to the bathroom and wash my hands
because i always get foundation on my
hands and then i do deodorant before i
get dressed
but yesterday so i put on deodorant in
the morning and then i left my house at
five o'clock to pay a ship call
and thank god the ship call was outside
because of covid but like i'm sitting at
the shiva call and i'm like
i think i smell and then i'm like i mean
i guess i didn't put on deodorant like
since this morning and it was like six
o'clock
but also i ran out of deodorant and i
told you i've been using like one of
ben's old ones that like definitely
doesn't even work anymore
i only use zax deodorant like i think
that men it is far
superior 100 not this particular one
that's like roll on from
actually seven years ago so i'm like i
was so i immediately got so embarrassed
and like i was like you just like hug
everyone
i was like clenching my armpits it is
the worst feeling in the world
yeah it is so that's me today plus no
coffee
even though you're now the coffee queen
so yeah i just couldn't really relate to
your struggle of not having a coffee
you also don't have a coffee you have a
milkshake okay excuse me this is a
latte with an espresso shot that is
coffee
it just happens to look like a milkshake
because of the sweet cream cold foam you
have but i assure you you have a coffee
flavored milkshake
no i have a grande ice blonde latte
with white mocha and sweet cream cold
foam that i got from starbucks that is
the newest installation
on my tic tac series make sure to head
over to girl with no job on tick tock to
uh
check out my progress because today's
look i never even drink more than a few
sips
if i don't like it but i would say i'm
35 there
yeah maybe more so is this the one see
the thing
is is that it could be the one but
what i'm really struggling with is like
of course all the drinks that i've ended
up liking which is basically
this and an iced caramel macchiato are
like 300 calories
and that's not really the point of the
coffee like the point of the coffee is
just to like
you know 100 calories [ __ ] and you [ __ ]
it out an hour later like
but i do have to say for those asking on
the journey update from my bowels like
we are moving things are moving and
grooving and honestly like i might just
keep up this
series till the end of time so i can be
consistently
moving my bowels so let me ask you
something if you are interested
in a coffee that's not soy
any answer yeah would you give a [ __ ]
what kind of pants instead of a [ __ ]
you should that literally sounded like
for coffee that's coffee and not
milkshake 300 calories
why do you even entertain these orders
because this sounds like a real coffee
that does not look like a real coffee
okay did i know the color
of it before i ordered it does this not
sound like a real coffee
uh iced blonde latte
is it a lot of milk oh it is
that's why it's so good and then you
also have cold cream on top of it
vanilla sweet cream cold foam that's
basically just frothed milk no
vanilla is that what makes it a lottery
cold foam
so there's two milks the milk and the
sweet cream cold foam anything that
sweet cream is just not going to be good
for you but it's
but it's good for my soul and i didn't
say you were looking for a drink that
was good for your soul then just go back
to your caramel macchiato i just want to
be like
you know like one of these girls washing
around you don't want to slash around
with that
like that is oh [ __ ] but it's so good
yeah i'm sure it's delicious but go get
a vanilla bean you want a sip
no tried it's so good no i'm like off
sugar and stuff like that'll just spike
all my glucose levels
oh my god you are literally a grandma
like if anything you were a grandma
before
this journey you went on really made you
into a full-blown senile
well you know what they they know what's
good
yeah the older folk a hundred percent
i can't wait to age gracefully god
willingly knock on wood not if you keep
drinking those
that's all i'll say oh my god you did
not
just shame me oh big time big time
especially because you say you want one
thing and then you show up with that
every day
have you met me like i say one thing and
i do the other like that's literally who
i am
i'm here to keep you on track you said
you want a coffee [ __ ] order a cold
brew
skim almond soy oat milk as you want i
can't put in half and half
you could put in half and a half but
then it's like a little bit less than
the others
yeah i don't really like your journey
i'm going to stick on mine okay but you
so good
you said you wanted i said what i said
yeah
and i did what i did go for some like
sugar-free pumps
and that'll get your bowels moving the
thing is is that
it's like a personal journey i don't
tell you how to do your no it's
literally not you're taking suggestions
no not from you i don't i didn't tell
you how to go on your predicting journey
i think maybe you should just like no
but get out of this you did try to tell
me
i'm here to support you and sometimes
support looks like tough love
you know what i guess this is i wasn't
all that supportive of your wellness
journey in the beginning and this now i
know what it feels like
right it doesn't feel good
you know what else doesn't feel good
this day last year
right if you know you know i don't
really feel like getting into it i just
um no but
to me it's not this day last year it's
um it was just like zack's birthday last
year yeah we already
we already passed it passed it yeah but
uh
i'll tell us just know all right tk rgk
is one year old
yeah cause that's where it came from
right yeah yeah cause real toaster is
new
that like we literally did nothing wrong
and ashley jessica wasn't even a real
person
let alone sorry ashley jessica rn yeah
um
i want to talk about bethany's new show
because first of all
you have to watch it like it was a
journey for me you know i'm a
huge bethany fan and the first episode
like the first like 20 minutes i was
like wow
i see what other people see when they
don't like bethany like she was coming
off
so like unlikable and
basically the premise of the show it's
like the apprentice she's looking for
her new
chief brand officer the truckers for
bethany have arrived um she's looking
for her new chief brand
officer so they cast like 10 people who
they thought were qualified
to compete in different tasks etc etc
sounds like a good premise literally she
gets to like the initial cocktail party
and she fires half the people like it's
so stupid sorry spoiler alert
and then it's like the people that we're
left with it's like
oh my god who did the casting on this
show like
none of them are qualified like for this
if this is a real job that exists of
skinny girl brand like
that's a huge brand like that's a huge
job and they literally have like
influencers and like this girl was like
i started my own sock company like it's
it was just like these people were in no
way qualified if you
ideally the person for this job like
needs an mba yeah it's like a really
serious job
this person was an event planner oh i do
brand and like bethany was like she was
like
this girl was like i helped you know
celebrities and influencers build their
brands
and bethany was like how and she's like
i get it done
and beverly was like like how like what
do you do step by step
she's like well we sit down and they
tell me what they need and i get it done
and that girl got sent home good yeah
like but even the people that we were
left with like they're
so twisted like they are just not
qualified in any way
and after the first episode i was like
wow this is like actual trash reality
tv they only released for the first two
episodes but then the second episode
like
it's kind of an amazing show like it's
so bad but it's so good
and i was left wanting more like i
couldn't believe i have to wait like
another week to get two more episodes
and then another week to get the finale
like
it's so good but there are a lot of
really weird things
about the show and i think the show
actually does a bad job of representing
bethany's brand and let me explain
she basically says like you know the
brand really lacks social media
like marketing they're not great at that
and that's what they need that's what
bethany needs and it's like
so you need a social media manager
that's still not a
chief brand officer the first talent was
they had like the chief brand officers
like making instagram stories pretending
they're influencers like promoting each
product
that's not the job of a chief brand
officer and it was so cringy to watch it
was like actually painful
but then it makes a brand look bad
because like bethany literally pulls out
like this big ass piece of like
paper with all of her different brands
like the podcast like all of the bethany
isms
and it's like this is a hundred million
dollar brand it's a piece of paper like
she just looks so disorganized and then
like the people
like who are her confidants like her
it's her assistant
her brand manager and then two of her
financial managers which is like you
have a personal financial manager
it was just like making no sense it
looks like her company was like so messy
and unstructured and like
even like the like all the products they
were just like all over the place like
bethany had them like test out different
products and one of the things was a
coffee syrup like basically like my
white mocha
and it didn't say coffee syrup on the
label so everyone thought it was alcohol
they were taking shots of it like
it just made her brand look so like
tacky and like messy
and it was really like weird and then it
also made bethany look so weird because
like
the first episode was filmed at like one
of her um investment properties in
greenwich it was just like this
turnt ass house in connecticut in the
suburbs and i was like why are they
filming a tv show here
it was so weird so it kind of made
bethany's brand look like kind of
illegitimate like
it gave me like a really weird vibe that
is really weird and but i did learn a
lot because she was like
you know the alcohol sold whatever but i
own 100 of the consumer brands like they
have salad dressing the popcorn i love
the popcorn
she said that the biggest um category
for her guests
like popcorn you know like all the
things that she makes
like she has the jeans on hsn like um so
like food would be a category jeans
would be a category
um shapewear did you even know she had
shapewear no no and that's her biggest
category
so i just felt like really i left the
episodes like feeling really confused by
her brand
yeah because it's not even about alcohol
anymore and i also like if i was her
chief brand officer i kept thinking i
would be the most
amazing contestant like the social media
video easy
like and then she just wants someone
who's like very straight up with her and
all these people are like so afraid of
her
i would literally be like bethany like
you have got to evolve like the
the logo like we need to change it up
also like i might recommend like a
rebrand like in 2021 i don't know if
we're saying the word skinny anymore
like
i just i think like the brand is a
little dated and that's really what i
took away from the show which i don't
think was
the point the takeaway the point was
like bethany's this boss boss boss
i don't know she came off kind of
annoying like she's talking to the
assistants and she's like i'm so
detail-oriented sorry i have to get up
because the centerpiece was like
off-centered at the table it was just so
performative
it was so like she was bothering me a
lot but like her life is like fabulous
like her outfits were great that's what
we wanted when we were watching her on
her last season of roni which was that
we just want bethany in her business
i feel like her business is extremely
legitimate i'm sure they had to find
holes in it in order for
the show to work like we need someone to
come in and fix all these things
but still that's not a good takeaway the
funny thing is that was that the whole
my like one of my biggest takeaways with
that was that the brand is like kind of
dated in the sense that they don't have
their social media down and it's like
no you're 100 right i've seen no
marketing for the show like i i only
stop because somebody posted about in
the toasters group
i haven't seen it on bethany's instagram
like where's the promo for this hbo mac
show
i don't know i guess the chief right
officer that she ended up hiring did not
do a good job
that's really interesting if there's a
season two i think that you should go on
it
by the way i agree i swear i would be so
good it's like you could do all these
challenges but like
a chief brand then they're not looking
for a chief brand because i'm not
qualified they're looking for a social
media manager
yeah so i just really unclear like and
then the second episode their
challenge was to photo direct a photo
shoot also not what a chief brand
officer does like that's what you
hire a director for for a photo shoot
like it was just so messy and all
over the place but this girl nicole
who's like the villain is literally
putting the show on her back like
you hate her but i can't imagine like
last night well not last night
the second episode was so good because
this girl lost
her [ __ ] mind and like bethany was
actually very cool calm and collected
even though this girl was
hella disrespectful but
like she's everything but she's also
nothing you know what i mean yeah okay
well you know what i think you've
influenced me to watch
i'm telling you it's good and i was
watching with tbg we were like calling
each other every five minutes we were
like this is so it's so good
that is so hysterical okay i'm gonna
watch i turned my tv on again
yesterday i caught up on real housewives
of dallas like i'm back watching tv
tonight is part one of the reunion
correct yes and rony premiere
rooney premiere i'm really excited real
houses of new york um i like
i'm excited i just don't feel like
they've shaken up the cast
like enough after losing tinsley and
duranda even though i didn't really like
love both of them like they both
added value in whatever twisted way that
it was so i'm like nervous actually
still feels like a small cast
did you know that liam mob is converting
to judaism i found that out yesterday
on her instagram story oh my god i'm so
excited for her
i know i wonder what the impetus is me
too a lot of times if you convert it's
cause like you
met someone who's jewish yes so but i
don't think she's dating anyone but
maybe she is
she actually is very interesting like
i'm excited to tune in for her i hope
she moved apartments
yes um so what else like what's going on
with you
nothing just you know catching up with
brew like we have
so much to like lost time to make up for
so we're just trying like bonding
spending time together like emotional it
is emotional
we were reading last night he was just
being like so sweet and cute
what was he reading he was reading the
hat he was reading theo's book
doctor for chapman without borders and
he said it was fantastic
has he read um of course oh okay okay of
course then he was reading the sequel
he got an advanced copy i can't believe
i actually haven't like promoted my book
in a while even though i did yesterday
very briefly but i don't know if you
guys know i read a book it's on amazon
literally anywhere you buy books it was
a new york times bestseller
i feel like once i became a bestseller
like stop talking about it i suddenly
got like koi but
i'm done doing that i'm a new york times
bestseller usa today bestseller wall
street journal bestseller kind of like
all of the best sellers in america and
canada and the number
two overall redheads pick which is
honestly it might be my greatest
accomplishment yeah he picked some
really
serious books and it's all genre it's
not just like all celebrity memoir or
all
non-fiction like i really kind of like
went up against and i didn't even expect
to make it past the first round and then
you came to me
i wasn't really paying attention and you
were like cause i just didn't want to
like have my feelings hurt
and i was like great i got out in the
first round and then you were like you
made it to the semi-final
finals and honestly that was enough for
me yeah you know
dying number two and number 12. don't
forget it and like honestly
the reviews that keep coming in and
what's the latest
everyone's just like not to be so
obnoxious like they're obsessed like
it's so good
like and i knew it's so good and i
always think everything i do like
is like my farts are like next level
genius yes so good but like dead ass
like this book not to compare to my
farts
is just like kind of like a sickening
tale of two titties
and i think that if you haven't read it
yet you should get it on kindle or on
audiobook or literally
anywhere you buy books especially since
summer's here pretty much and this is a
beach read
people are saying it's the book of
summer it's the book of the season
yeah and i'm the diamond of the suit
you're the diamond of the season this is
the book of the season
if you find yourself on a beach soon
this falls under the beach read category
it does and honestly even if you don't
like to read like the cover is kind of
sickening and
olivia has it i have like a million um
my cabinets it's decor like yeah and
then like if you're like taking a
picture on the beach like
the it's a little pop of color if you
know you're just
sunbathing and someone walks by and
they're like ooh bathtub like oh my god
girls my job like
it's just a great conversation starter
it's also just a great way to find
toasters in the wild it's like a magnet
for toaster energy
hundred percent and if you use jackie
o'fly on your pictures like it's
guaranteed the flow plus like the
millennial pink cover double the likes
guaranteed double the likes
have you watched um the new season of
younger yet no is it out
it's out six episodes on hulu they all
came out together
no i don't know they did like a weird
release taylor striker was explaining it
to me because you know she hosts the
after show
they released four on paramount plus
like as a paramount plus
hoopla thing and i went to go subscribe
and it was literally ten dollars and
everyone was like the interface sucks so
i decided against it but then i found
out it's on hulu
and now they've been releasing them
weekly and they're up to the sixth
episode it's
so good like liza is the worst
and like that's what makes it so good
because like honestly she's just like
going through it right now and i'm just
like living for it oh yeah
debbie mazar has a more developed role
like good and so does lauren
i didn't finish last season i don't
think
it's real it's i just remember like
charles and liza were together and then
like all the problems started you know
of course like they can't just ever like
let us live right so i was just like
turned it off
plus since i watched the bowl type and
it's literally the same show
i was in bold type mode and i just i
felt traitorous it's the same type of
show maybe i should watch bull type like
i'm really craving more younger
you would love hate bold type no like i
hate being frustrated watching a tv
show it's so conflicting there's so much
to love and there's so much to hate
i think you should watch it i think it
would like i think you would be really
invested
i just love like you know shows about
like fake workplaces like no it's
it is that like nobody ever looks ugly
or tired and it's like they're all just
magically fulfilled by their jobs and
they have time to like get breakfast
before work yeah and like
and then walk to work oh and then yeah
and like also meet up with the guy that
they're talking to and like return his
sweatshirt no these people don't get
tired
they do not get tired they wake up at
5am and they go to sleep at 2 a.m and
they're so fulfilled they're so
fulfilled but you should watch younger
okay and i'll watch them all type what
what is it on
hulu oh yes it's on hulu no younger is
so good and it's also the final season
so now it's like basically like aiden
and big you know it's like a whole thing
like charles and liza period
of course you literally can't understand
or relate to people who think
there are people liza and josh people
think like that's what's going to happen
in the end taylor striker would not tell
me what happened
but there's a lot of people who think
like she ends up with josh like he was
the otp all along
no way charles was the only actually
though
now like seeing how monstrous liza is
her and josh are perfect for each other
charles actually like the fact that
charles is slumming it with liza
is like so it's so upsetting because
like
char like he should just i don't want to
spoil it but like it's just
not the right fit okay talk about two
people who like are not compatible
okay wow i went and you know i'm such
like a
i always go for like the traditional i
was such a big girly you know i loved
aydah and what's going on with stephanie
bridgerton
oh she's like not really there there's
just like a lot a lot of weird things
going on
i guess because of kovid daphne
bridger10 like literally
is irrelevant diana literally my
favorite character is not in this season
not watchable then no i know but then i
guess like lauren kind of gets her air
time and lauren is really like
the star of the show like i'm dead
serious like she's just each season she
gets like funnier and funnier and she's
really so great
she's the star and also debbie mazar
gets like more of a developed
storyline and i just live for her so
it's good i just need less liza like for
real like she's so intolerable
kelsey and i'm watching the show i'm
like how did anyone not to be mean
everything this girl was 25. like
how are these people blind
she's not when i watched it like the
first seasons
when everyone really thought she was 26
like i really thought the casting was so
perfect because she really
could be 26. but this lie was not
sustainable because by season six
like yeah she she couldn't pass her 25.
but i agree like the crazy thing was it
was like who was this woman she's
literally 40 but 25 like yeah it was
kind of brilliant
they casted it perfectly but i'm so glad
they got over that whole
live storyline eliza
because by season five and six like it's
so not believable
but we're past that what's going on with
kelsey
literally nothing and she's also
becoming like really annoying like the
show isn't about kelsey and liza anymore
like
it's about everyone else and i feel like
they did a good job of like it's almost
like sex in the city like
of course carrie wasn't what's
interesting at first but then it's like
i kind of find myself wanting to
hear what's going on with charlotte and
samantha miranda more than i even give a
[ __ ] about harry
and it's the jaren star effects like i
literally care about the the tiniest
characters
more than i care about liza and guess
who's a new character this season
who heather mooney oh
from from romy michelle romeo michelle
she plays like a college professor who
uh did she play an entrepreneur who
invented quick burning cigarettes
no but that is kind of her coming of age
story that's like before she became a
professor
that was what she did oh okay cool yeah
it's like her prequel okay
i'm gonna watch wow okay i guess i'm not
getting anything done today because i
have to watch
bethany show younger bethany show will
take you five minutes like it's
literally two episodes and they're 30
minutes
okay fine i think brew will be into that
because he doesn't really know bethany
because he was born after her time on
roni wow
imagine being i mentioned growing up
with like a post bethany
rooney era can't relate can't relate so
brew will be excited about that
and now i think without further ado it
is time you know
100 sense time pretty fast stories that
you need to know
yeah you before you wake up and take a
bite out of your morning toast
and today's episode is brought to you by
frambridge framebridge makes it easier
and more affordable than ever to frame
your favorite things
without ever leaving the house add a
gallery wall to your home office or send
the perfect gift
from art prints and diplomas to photos
sitting in your phone you can frame
bridge just about anything
here's how it works go to
framebridge.com and upload your photo or
they'll send you a package to safely
mail in your physical pieces
you can preview your item online in
dozens of different frame styles and
gallery wall layouts
you choose your favorite or you can get
free recommendations from their talented
designers
the experts at frame bridge will custom
frame your item and deliver your
finished piece directly to your door
ready to hang instead of the hundreds
you'd pay at a framing store their
prices start at 39
and all shipping is free plus our
listeners can get 15
off their first order at framebridge.com
when they use the code
toast uh framebridge is literally the
most genius thing ever the framing
industry is like so outdated and so
expensive and it should not
cost more to frame like a piece of art
than the actual piece of art cost and
like i have been there so
frame bridge is so easy the free
shipping is everything the fact that you
can just like upload photos from your
phone
makes it so easy because you have so
many fabulous photos sitting on your
phone that like you never do anything
with
and they should be hanging in your home
yes get started today frame your photos
or send someone the perfect gift
mother's day is coming up
go to framebridge.com use the promo code
toast to save an additional 15
off your first order go to
framebridge.com promo code toast
framebridge.com promo code toast okay
are you ready to get into it um i think
i feel ready like i had a coffee you
know i'm just like a coffee girly
ugh can't relate first story bill and
melinda gates are ending their marriage
the gates's are getting divorced after
27 years
the pair announced in a statement on
their twitter accounts
they said after a great deal of thought
and a lot of work on our relationship we
have made the decision to end our
marriage
this is so crazy and let me tell you why
tell us
obviously it's crazy because how long
were they married 37 27 whatever um
a huge accomplishment so happy for them
but at some point
it's like just same sorry you know like
yeah like what are they gonna go and do
now
no like 27 like i don't know i just
can't imagine there's so much at stake
here too
but see that's the other thing is there
what do you mean didn't they pledge like
all their money half their money they
pledged to charity
and they gave their kids like a dollar
each did they do that like they give
each kid a million dollars which
obviously is a lot of money not for the
gates is but
yes if i was a kid i'd be kind of pissed
like really i flew private my whole life
and now all i have is a million dollars
well i'm sure there's like
more to trust in that yeah trust me i'm
sure they have like credit card
oh you think dates a hundred percent
mostly students would be like
protesting no that they like that is
crazy i'm sure it's just like
it's a good look for them to be like we
keep our kids right what
one million dollars but like i'm sure
they have like a credit card and
access but what about the foundation
like that's kind of
the charity world is quaking over this
it's like it's a big deal it's a big
deal
is it going to become the bill gates
foundation and the melinda gates
foundation to separate foundations or is
it going to remain
the bill and melinda gates foundation i
want to say it's going to remain
because i would think that like you know
the charity
is the charity world is everything to
them no and like the charity takes
precedent over personal matters
but if they were able to just like put
things aside and work on things then
they wouldn't be getting divorced
right so i think maybe but this might be
an opportunity for the charity world to
get the bill gates foundation and the
melinda gates foundation and that would
be
sensational but this is going to be one
of those things where like they're so
rich even
them giving away half their money like
when they get divorced they're still
both going to stay on like the forbes
list you know
yeah it's like mckenzie yeah yeah so
how much money do they have 137 billion
is his net worth
shut the [ __ ] up and i read that there's
no prenup
oh well of course because she met him
when she he was uh 27 years ago was he
nothing
they were bringing in microsoft oh yes
melinda okay here's the thing
and this is this might be like one of
the most controversial statements i have
ever said okay but honestly like
137 billion like just doesn't add up
like microsoft is a losery ass company
like
i haven't used microsoft since literally
99 like when paint was everything and
the solitaire like minecraft world was
just so important like
so i don't know that's just like really
losery company and i don't get how you
go from that
of course you'll be rich if you invented
microsoft 100 but 137 billion
just doesn't add up i think is a lot of
different i agree i hear what you're
saying it's kind of like what we were
saying yesterday like about like aol
like yeah
but like he literally invented the
internet and like how
i don't know i don't know but then also
he has his hand in a lot of things yes
like i like how he's like he has become
the face for like internet jokes about
just like
um illuminati so like i think the
illuminati crowd is
quaking like what does this mean he's
become the face of internet jokes like
about like
vaccine consumption illuminati you know
no but that's like illuminati's a bigger
umbrella of
like conspiracy theories and he's the
face of this
pod of like vaccine pandemic conspiracy
yeah i mean i don't know why people
would say that because like when i got
my shot i felt totally fine i just like
dreamt about bill gates for three years
straight
and i was just like and then you found
yourself walking to the microsoft store
oh my god i can't stop my arms and legs
no so he's just like a funny guy and
like honestly
i'm just i think that the illumina like
the the 4chan crowd like whoever makes
up all these conspiracy theories like
they're freaking out like
what does this mean what does this mean
because like bill gates is more
pertinent than ever
right now and by the way did he even
have anything to do with the vaccine
like
creation like money or anything um i
think that he
has like money invested in pharma
companies
i don't know like why him i i'm not too
deep
why not dolly parton you know
conspiracy the scale is different plus
there was that ted talk he
gave that like where he talked about
that's why where he talked about the
inevitability of a pandemic
and then um people thought he started it
yes
but like it was kind of like a little
off
not at all no but by the way people have
been saying that forever like the gross
like we were disgusting we still are
like no and if you watch
there was a netflix show that came out
like right before covid
called pandemic that was like kind of
like a docu-series about like studying
different
diseases and it became clear like this
was not a
an if but a when yeah yeah so that was
just like a bad ted talk for
for bill gates's reputation yeah so and
then plus like the divorce it's like
what does mckenzie know
yeah no what did she find out no and
it's like if mcca no not mckenzie
melinda
if melinda like mysteriously disappears
then we know something's up yes yes just
keep an eye
keep your eyes on melinda yeah this is
some pretty spooky stuff no but this was
like a shocking notification to get
because like at some point
it's the karen huger institution it's
like you just don't even realize that
bill and melinda hypothetically
could get divorced because like they're
just not yeah i agree
well prayers for the kids it's hard to
be a child of divorce even with a
hundred and
no i think actually 137 million dollars
just about covers nothing can hurt your
feelings
okay are you ready for our next story we
have a lot of men in the news today men
men will smith is saying he's in the
worst
shape of his life that this might have
been my favorite thing will smith's ever
done will smith got real with his
instagram followers on sunday in a pic
that he said shows him
with a very the stars they're just like
us look the action hero looks super
relatable on the candid shot of him
hanging outside near a lake wearing just
spandex workout shorts and an unzipped
track
jacket he said i'm gonna be real with
y'all i'm in the worst shape of my life
let me tell you why i was so funny
because of course like i'm scrolling and
i see the picture and
my first thought because i'm like a
judgmental person i'm like oh my god wow
like he's put on weight like not not in
a good or a bad way but like that was my
thought
and i just never expected him to be so
direct in addressing it in his caption
and it just like made me love him so
much like
everyone is in the worst shape of their
life even will smith 100
it made me feel like so i really like
that was
a moment for the first time in a while
where i'm like wow stars they're just
like us
yes and i feel like at every corner
stars are
just so desperately trying to
communicate to us that they are just
like us when in fact
they are not at all like us and will
smith like i just had a lot of respect
for this because first of all the
caption was so funny and second of all
like
will smith like can literally have like
a chef a trainer
like a gym in his house and even he's
that working out it's like why should i
yeah no it definitely like was
nice to see and very relatable and i
appreciate the honesty
100 and just the way he like worded his
caption was very funny hysterical what
was it again i'm gonna be real with you
i'm gonna be
real with y'all by the way like
literally you know there are these
companies that um
like frame print and frame and like
laminate
iconic tweets from celebrities like need
this one hanging over my bed
yeah totally and also speaking of um
mail weight gain news mark wahlberg
no it's part of the same story mark
wahlberg is sharing before and after
snaps of a 20 pound weight gain in three
weeks
he's gained 20 pounds he's gained 20
pounds in three weeks on tuesday he
showed off his 20 pound weight gain in
three weeks on instagram
after revealing last month that he
planned to gain 30 pounds in six weeks
for his role as a boxer turned priest in
the film father stew
here are the pictures oh my god so
everyone's just like getting really real
with us can i tell you something i
didn't realize this was for a role i
thought this was like by accident
do you remember when we were talking
about morgan stewart like had gotten
like some backlash for like her
post-baby body
for being the snatcher for being the
snatcher and i was just like well when
morgan stewart does it like it doesn't
bother me like maybe
like if someone else did it it would
have bothered me so
will smith being real with us like
doesn't bother me i'm empowered by it
but like mark wahlberg like
shut up like do you know what i mean
yeah they essentially did the same thing
but like i find will so endearing i'm a
bigger fan of will smith than i was
before and mark wahlberg like seriously
like shout out
no and also like having to gain weight
for a roll like talk about not relatable
imagine having
that much control of your weight that
you can gain and lose
for work no getting paid to gain weight
the dream if that were the case i would
be the next melinda gates
totally um but everyone's just getting
real
so we're all just getting fat we are
some of us are trying to turn the tides
some of us are also not having success
and some of us are drinking milkshakes
you know wellness looks different for
everyone um you know what else looks
different for everyone
what i don't know but today's episode is
brought to you by ipvanish
we're welcoming a new sponsor to the
show ipvanish we love a new sponsor to
the show do you wanna know what ipvanish
is
of course i want everyone to know what
ipvanish is it's a virtual private
network which is a vpn a super important
tool that helps you safely browse the
internet
you can use a vpn on your computer as
tablets phone even things like your fire
stick when you're streaming media
when you use a vpn all your data is
encrypted what you're reading what
you're searching what you're watching
whatever it is that you're doing
it's important because what you're doing
on the internet is no one else's
business but yours
ipvanish helps you remain anonymous and
secure on the internet
for listeners of the show ipvanish is
offering an incredible 65
off just 3.49 for the first month or
31.49
for the year here's everything you get
with ipvanish
anonymous ip addresses this means your
personal ip address can't be tracked by
anyone on the web
you can circumvent any online censorship
ipvanish has more than
1500 servers in 70 plus locations i used
actually
um ipvanish when i was in the british
virgin islands to access the megan and
harry interview because it wasn't
available there yet
and you also get 24 7 support email them
chat with them even call them they're
there to help
so this is great and i feel like for a
lot of the former toasters listening if
you want to troll us anonymously so we
can't find your ip addresses you should
check out ipvanish this one goes out to
you it's really affordable
and it'll protect you go to ipvanish.com
toast if you want the special savings
which is 65
off they have plans starting at just
3.49 or like we said 31.49
a year this is the time to sign up with
our discount code and their current
promotional offer
you can get a vpn for 65 off their usual
offering
ipvanish is the best of the best even
rated 4.7 out of 5
on trustpilot and that's with more than
6 000 reviews
i p v a n i s h
dot com slash toast is the link to get
the special offer
start protecting yourself online with
ipvanish love it
okay next story adam sandler has a
hilarious response to being turned away
from ihop
yes so last week a 17 year old long
island hostess diana rodas didn't
recognize adam sandler
and told him it would be a 30-minute
wait for a table at ihop in
menhasset after she realized her mistake
she made a tick-tock about the
experience garnering more than
9 million views she found the security
footage of her literally turning adam
sandler away and he was
so cool and he was like okay cool bye
yes she said not realizing it's adam
sandler and telling him it's a 30 minute
wait and him of course leaving because
he's not going to wait 30 minutes for
ihop
i want to okay so let's say she knew it
was adam sandler
right um i was in line first like why do
you get to cut
like no i i agree it would have been
cool like oh you're adam sandler i love
your movies it's 30 minutes like
i don't understand like whether or not
she knew like why they're famous why
don't you have to wait in line with the
rest of us stars they are just like us
get in line you know if that's the rule
like i would like to skip some lines
like i just
i think it's funny that you didn't know
who he was but i don't like the
assumption that like
right what would that have changed what
would have been different you know i
told i agree with you
um and so he responded to the viral tick
tock saying for the record i only left
the ihop because the nice woman told me
the all-you-can-eat deal didn't apply to
the milkshakes well he should have hung
out with you and maybe
and he'd be fine i have his milk cakes i
didn't know that
uh honestly this is like just great pr
for ihop because now i need a pancake
and a milkshake do you remember when
ihop rebranded to ihop
yeah but it was like an april fool's
prank unclear they never
followed up they never cleared that one
up so like in my mind i keep like
whenever i see an ihop i'm like oh they
haven't changed their logo yet like i
they never like followed up the joke or
like
made it full circle that's the danger of
april fool's jokes 100
your announcement of the joke has to be
as big and as well received as the
actual follow-up of the joke
yeah i totally agree but in the meantime
adam sandler didn't eat at ihop and
that's a
tragic story it is it's a tragedy
you know adam sandler um like lives near
nyu
and he plays basketball in like the
there's like two gyms one of them is
like
obviously like some new sponsor just put
it in because it's like sickeningly
stunning
it looks like a planet fitness and then
another one is called kohl's and it's
like an
actual dump like there's rats everywhere
nobody uses it
but adam sandler goes there every day to
play basketball and he walks around
nyu like in his basketball shorts so i
actually have seen adam sandler so this
story is kind of personal to me
oh yeah he's definitely thinking of you
when he wrote that tweet
oh he responded in tweet form oh i don't
know where he responded probably not a
tweet i just assume everything is
are you ready for our next story because
finally some respect well
it's not finally sometimes it happens
but some respect is being put on pink's
name
finally she's receiving the icon award
at the billboard music awards
she says that she feels humbled and
honored as she should
pink is set to be honored with the icon
award at the billboard music awards on
may 23rd people can exclusively announce
the singer will also hit the stage for a
hit
filled performance oh my god it's going
to be like her has she done the super
bowl yeah
no she should oh you said that before
that she should yeah maybe that's what i
thought
she a hundred percent feels like a good
first step
yes because she has people don't realize
like
hit after hit she's literally they start
coming and they
don't stop coming come to know him and
hit the ground running
people don't realize like for literally
every phase of my life in the last 15
years like there is a pink song
associated with it
and she does not get enough respect but
she like
is so like she doesn't care
do you know what i mean about any of
that [ __ ] yeah she doesn't need all
these awards
and accolades she sells major tickets
like her
songs perform so well like she doesn't
need any sort of um
validation but i'm sure it feels nice
yeah and it's nice for the fans you know
because then we got
you know a pink medley performance at
the billboard music awards and now i
have a greater chance of watching
you know what i think it is with pink i
think there's probably like
millions of people who are like fans of
hers but she doesn't have like
a lot of like number one fans like stan
everyone just like likes pink
nobody like would get hit by a bus for
her like they would like ariana grande
you know but i think that that is
probably
a part of her longevity and like her
mental health
for sure super toxic to have like that
type of
yeah because you know adoration it
it's not sustainable it's not
sustainable and
it's can turn yeah so i think that's
what it's like
no one if i had five tickets to a ping
concert i don't think i would find one
person who would say no like everyone
just like likes her you know
yeah yeah like someone couldn't come
right and her talent like is there the
singing the dancing the
tricks in the sky like the acrobatics
the acrobatics thank you that's the word
i was looking for they're there for sure
so bbmas maybe i'll be watching an award
show we shall see the bbmas are usually
pretty good they usually are good
because they just like play the songs
that like
charted so the songs that actually do
well not the songs like the grammys
decide are good
yes agreed so are you ready to get into
our fifth and final story
is it the fifth and final story
yes it is yeah nyc's bougiest restaurant
11 madison park
goes completely vegan 11 madison park
one of the world's most acclaimed
restaurants has announced its menu is
going vegan according to a statement by
chef owner daniel hum
on monday an exclusive interview with
the wall street journal the swiss-born
chef said
if 11 madison park is truly at the
forefront of dining and culinary
innovation
to me it's crystal clear that this is
the only place to go
next this is crazy so 11 madison park is
like the fanciest restaurant
in new york city have you ever eaten
there um no but they did a pop-up in the
hamptons and i ate at that one
i ate at the one in new york and i got
so sick because the food was so rich
and like everything's coming out literal
gout i got gout from
well like allegedly we don't want
anything like that but like
the food is so rich there's so many
courses everything comes out hot cold
it's just like
a lot it's a tumultuous on the stomach
but they're going vegan and so i feel
like i have like i don't know maybe
i should try it again plant-based
plant-based
the same thing yes the re-launch menu is
described as well no it's not the exact
same thing because vegan also cuts out
other stuff you could be plant-based
and not vegan but if you're vegan you're
plant-based
got it i know that didn't make clear
the relaunch menu is described as an
8-10 course menu in the main dining room
consisting of entirely plant-based
dishes
the three michelin star restaurant at
24th and madison in manhattan will
reopen for service on june 10th
let me say something i'm really happy
that the vegans have a fancy place to
eat like they deserve it 100
they work so hard but i just hope this
doesn't become a trend because the kind
of meal you can
look forward to at 11 madison a literal
garden in a
literal bowl of just lettuce oh and that
will cost you 67
and some apples yeah no it's um 355
oh no it's the average price tag is 500
because you have to buy
you buy the experience and so it's
hundreds of dollars per person
you're getting like 10 courses so i just
hope like whatever grade like there are
very rich fancy vegans who might want
like a night out on the town and they
deserve that
i just hope this isn't a thing that like
popular restaurants start to do
because like us carnivores like we still
gotta eat
i don't know i'm i'm not not here for it
like i do feel for the carnivores of
course but like for me personally if
everything were plant-based i would
if i could look at a menu in order
anything i wanted from it that would be
a whole new experience but most people
can't do that whether it's religious
allergies taste i
pretty much i eat like mostly like i
don't have that many restrictions
allergy wise and kosher wise like i have
a few but like i literally i'll go to a
menu and i'm like where's the chicken
and where's the salmon that's the only
two things right
okay so say like the world was trending
towards like only serving chicken salmon
french fries and chicken nuggets like
and they were going to make all
different versions like with those
ingredients like yeah what do you look
forward to that
thrilling like you'd be like sorry
everyone but this is my time to shine
yeah oh wow no you're now that you put
it in that perspective
you're 100 right that sounds amazing and
then you could look at a menu and
literally anything
you would like anything that's on it you
know like that's why i love going to
mcdonald's like the menu is really just
like
claudia friendly yeah there's so many
different types of chicken sandwiches
and types of different nuggets
spicy tender like it's just it's
thrilling
yeah and the sides oh my god i can't
even like
get into it so exciting um so the love
in madison park story is interesting one
it's like the fanciest restaurant but
also like could they be a trendsetter is
this the way that the world is going
in churasan it's considered the fanciest
restaurant like in the world right
or in the city in the city which is like
the fanciest city
one if by land is actually considered
the fanciest in the city you think so
um before we wrap up but now they're
going to have to just cut it one if by
plant based too if by
getting not even by sea because that's
not plant-based two if by farm-raised
fish
right because you know that i was having
farm-raised fish for the past two weeks
and
it tasted amazing do you feel like you
raised i
wish farm-to-table fish wait farm-raised
yes
they don't live on farms that's why it's
crazy they like
fish tank and create them in the fish
tank
sounds like you're making this up i'm
not i swear farm-raised fish look it up
um before we wrap up today's show i do
have a little mindlessness that i would
like to share no
and that's brought to you by public
goods i'm obsessed with public book
goods
they basically make all the products you
need for your home some of my favorites
are the all-purpose like a surface
cleaner
perfect for your countertops your dining
room table it smells so good so it's
literally like
cleaning and also lighting a candle like
it just leaves your home smelling fresh
i love the hand soap it comes in this
very chic all of their branding it's
like very elegant and chic so it's like
you i accidentally left my surface
cleaner out when i have company that's
okay
she's elegant as [ __ ] right it's like
she cleans and she's elegant
public goods is the one-stop shop for
sustainable high-quality everyday
essentials made from clean ingredients
at an affordable price everything from
coffee to toilet paper and shampoo to
pet food
public goods is your new everything
store thoughtfully designed for the
conscious consumer
rather than buying from a bunch of
single product brands public goods
members can buy all of their premium
essentials in one place
with one beautiful streamlined aesthetic
public goods searches the globe to find
clean healthy eco-friendly and
innovative products
so like i said the service cleaner being
clean is great because i you know
sprayed all around theo and i don't want
to have like a million chemicals around
him
of course so it's just nice to know that
i don't have to worry about any of that
you know 100 they also have these
delicious chocolate almonds
yes that were so good wolf down in a day
thanks public goods all their products
are ethically sourced and
they obsessively develop each of their
products to be free of unhealthy
ingredients and harmful additives
that are still common in drug and
grocery store shelves they are committed
to making their products healthy and
safe for humans
animals more importantly and the
environment you it's nice to know what's
in your products and that where they
come from is important small changes in
the way we shop
can make a big impact on personal health
and the world at large they use a
membership model to keep costs low and
pass
on even more savings to their customers
best of all you can make a first
purchase with no obligation
and they plant one tree for every order
placed and incorporate sustainability
into every part of the company
join hundreds of thousands of others who
have switched to their new everything
store
guys it's literally the everything of
the sort store because they have
everything and all the products are
everything of the sort
um we've got a great deal for you guys
you can get 15 off your first public
goods order with no minimum purchase
so they are so confident that you will
love their products and come back again
that they are giving you 15 to spend on
your first purchase you know no
questions asked
plus right now you can receive your
choice of a free pack of bamboo straws
or reusable food storage wraps with your
order i have to say the bamboo straws
are some of the best sustainable straws
i've used
from public goods like they're the best
um
and you literally have nothing to lose
at publicgoods.com toast
or you can just use code toast public
p-u-b-l-i-c-g-o-o-d-s
dot com forward slash toast to receive
that 15 off your first order that's
public goods
so good yes don't be confused with
public good morning millennials
um okay a little kelly's mindless news
like the 4th of july
this segment is in no way sponsored by
kelly rip or any of her family friends
or acquaintances we apologize for
demands for any friends we may cause but
kelly just makes it way too easy
no kelly's pr team just makes it way too
easy kelly ripa
wow's in a gorgeous
swimsuit for sun soaked anniversary
selfie with mark consuelos
so just with that headline tell me an
oxymoron because how are you wowing in a
swimsuit when you're taking a selfie
precisely but just if you were a typical
consumer who wasn't
uh abreast on the mindlessness that is
okay so i'm gonna say
even though it's a selfie and she's
wowing in a swimsuit maybe they did that
zoom out feature on selfie you ever do
that where you're taking a selfie and
then you press that button it zooms out
a little bit
maybe she got a high angle until she's
wowing in her swimsuit next to her
husband
kelly ripa had all the feels on saturday
don't forget that there's major sun
as it is sun soaked and it's like
crystal clear and like sickening
like when you're standing directly in
the sunlight like you have yeah like
honestly like a kylie jenner selfie like
when she stands in the sun and somehow
like doesn't squish she's like
yeah yeah right okay that's kelly okay
kelly ripa had all the feels on saturday
as she marked her 25th wedding
anniversary with husband mark consuelos
and even though we're making fun
that is a huge feat bill and melinda
twenty seconds tapped out to 27 let's
see how they how far they go
the live with kelly and ryan star and
her actor spouse each shared a variety
of photos
to publicly celebrate their love for
each other on social media
what this one stood out to hello
magazine because one in particular
posted on kelly's instagram
saw her and mark display their
age-defying looks as they soaked up the
sun surrounded by palm trees
kelly looked phenomenal in a monochrome
swimsuit as she posed makeup free on her
knees
bending towards the camera and flashing
a beaming smile
mark looked equally incredible rocking a
pair of black swimming shorts and a
baseball cap as he displayed
his toned physique running across the
image kelly said
happy 25th baby so i just have to say
before i show you what this like blurry
ass like piece of [ __ ] image looks like
it's worth noting like kelly ripa and
mark consuelos are literally like
probably two of the people in the
industry who look best for their age
like
i can't tell who looks better him or her
like they both are snatched and like are
just like stunning i just don't really
feel like this image was newsworthy and
i'm gonna show it to you and of course
we will post it
in my head i'm just thinking of the two
of them like on a beach direct sunlight
like sickening
her and her monochromatic this is
literally taken on an android
and it's a story it's a story like so
her
shitty quality story makes news make it
make it make sense
make it make sense and she's like not
even in the picture and her
monochromatic suit she's bending over
you can't even see her bathing suit
that's that ain't right and this
screenshot like
this looks like the same person who's
running bethany's like social media like
it's just not
it's not it's just not it and it like is
an otherwise cute photo there just
doesn't need to be an article about it
no exactly and it's like that's what
makes kelly's mindless news so
frustrating it's like
there's there is actually like stuff to
talk about when it comes to kelly ripa
but they're just choosing like the most
mindless yeah no but it's definitely an
effective strategy because now i
associate kelly rippo with mindlessness
as opposed to like
controversy yeah could be worse for
kelly ripa yeah
that's true actually maybe that's the
they're like inundating us
and the more we talk about it like the
more we're fueling this machine but we
are on to something
100 no this is this the pr strategy for
kelly ripa's team like
inundate them with mindlessness and i
just hate it's like
it's like that and they'll get so sick
of hearing about her and talking about
her that they won't spend time talking
about the things we don't want them to
talk about
that's true but it kind of feels like
you know introducing the pussycat tabs
when they were like
putting the subliminal messaging through
the
music for the youth like i just don't
really feel like good about the fact
that like kelly's pr team has like
decided to kind of
subliminally subliminally message us and
like mess with our minds so that's why i
do the work that i do when it comes to
kelly's mindlessness no calling it out
but i also think
that the first step is like knowing that
you're being messed with exactly and
we've taken that step
and honestly that's like all we can do
you know it's it's out of our control
call it out when you see it haul it out
when you see it um so that's a little
kelly's mindless news and we hope that
it was mindless enough for you we do um
anything you want to like say
oh we actually have a great guest on the
show tomorrow yes we do so that will be
really fun and exciting tomorrow is
humpty dear toaster so exciting rooney
premiere tomorrow is going to be a big
day
dallas reunion i mean it is going to be
a long show tomorrow
and also i have so much tv to watch
today so if i thought i was going to be
like you know up and out i'm working out
like
cleaning out my closet maybe tomorrow
well tomorrow actually i am cleaning out
my closet with
my favorite home organizers done
hilarious mother daughter duo and i'm
going to patreon vlog it because like
i just feel like at least for me i don't
really get
as much done unless i'm vlogging because
i have something to prove like i want to
want people to think i'm disgusting like
i can have dirty underwear everywhere
no it holds you accountable right yeah
so that'll be on the patreon
and a bunch of fabulous things happening
this month on the patreon patreon.com
morning toast uh 7.99 cents to get five
extra episodes from jackie and i
month their vlogs their podcasts they're
really anything you want them to be and
you can request personal episodes
because once you become a member
you get access to the facebook group
which is the last remaining facebook
group uh the toast after dark so 7.99
five free episode five episodes five uh
fabulous memories and access to the
facebook group and
a great way to support your favorite
gals yes also last month was such
a bang-up month content content content
content content no sleep
if you have like so many questions about
my retreat like
go to the patreon every single one of
them is answered in my vlog we did a q a
like i'm getting to the heart of the
matter
if you just like want to know what i was
up to in the last two weeks
it's so important to get down to the
heart of the matter it's so important
because
you know what i said um that's our show
you guys thank you so much for listening
to
our show no one else's don't get it
twisted do not
get it twisted like no one else is
taking credit for no one wants to be
associated with us
thank you guys so much for listening to
the morning shows the millennium morning
show where we deliver the best five
stories that you need to know every
monday through friday on youtube so
if you're watching this on youtube
please feel free to subscribe and give
this video a thumbs up
we're also available as a podcast
anywhere podcast can be found so it's
spotify i didn't stitch your public
radio i have already catapults all the
places so wherever you listen to podcast
find us morning chill sleep applies to
our view about how beautiful
stunning and smart we are we'll see you
guys tomorrow
hump day goodbye goodbye